welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Sascha Turner who was at Yale as a
visiting fellow at the Gilder Lehrman
Center for the Study of slavery and
abolition at the Macmillan Center she is
an associate professor of history at
Quinnipiac University where she teaches
courses on the Caribbean and the African
diaspora
women piracy colonialism and slavery her
research has been published in the
Journal of Women's History slavery and
abolition and Caribbean studies today
we'll talk with professor Turner about
her new book contested bodies pregnancy
child rearing and slavery in Jamaica
welcome professor Turner thanks for
having me let's begin with an overview
of your book tell us about it so my book
is a history of the ending of the
transatlantic slave trade and this is a
slave trade to the British colonies and
I focused specifically on the trade to
Jamaica or at least the impact of the
end of the trade to Jamaica it's a
really complicated story there are many
characters that I have to keep track of
so they're abolitionists who are mostly
campaigning in England there are British
parliamentarians there are lawmakers in
Jamaica they were slaveholders who I
sometimes refer to as planters and of
course they're the enslaved people in
slave women and children and so the book
is really a study of conflicts among all
those characters over how the slave
trade ends a lot of us are familiar with
the process of the ending of the slave
trade in the British colonies and
there's a debate a lively debate among
historians about whether or not the
slave trade ended for humanitarian
reasons or economic reasons my book
really doesn't talk about that much it
has implications for that debate but the
conflict that my book talks about is
really the proposal that abolitionists
made to end the slave trade not in mid
but for peered off 10 to 15 years sab
illusionist came up with this idea where
they said well you know something the
abolitionists of the period previous
error from the 1760s about the 1770s
tried to abolish the slave trade before
but they didn't succeed and they didn't
succeed because they wanted to end the
slave trade immediately and that didn't
work because obviously the slave trade
was very profitable and there were many
in England who were very well-connected
and very wealthy who supported and
benefited from the slave trade and so
the group of abolitionists who emerge in
the 1780s had understood very well they
had learned from the previous
abolitionists of the 1760s and if they
came out to demand an immediate end to
the abolition of the slave trade that it
was unlikely to work so they came up
with this very elaborate plan and the
elaborate plan was you know what if we
proposed ending the slave trade
or continuing the slave trade for
another ten to fifteen years and during
that ten to fifteen years we would
encourage planters just to shift their
dependence from the slave trade towards
reproduce in the population locally and
the idea was that planters dependent on
the slave trade because the local slave
population in Jamaica did not reproduce
naturally and they came up with several
arguments why the slave trade did not
reproduce naturally they said the sex
ratio between men and women were
imbalance they said slavery was so
horrific in terms of the working
conditions in terms of the living
conditions of the enslaved in terms of
the kinds of work that the enslaved were
required to perform and of course the
punishment in terms of how they were
treated and so abolitionist said to the
planters you know what if you were to
improve upon those conditions and will
allow the slave trade to continue for
ten to fifteen years while you improve
the condition while you continue to
import and slave people to balance out
acts in that sex ratio and so you know
they had these wonderful ideas on how
they would you know end the slave trade
but of course they didn't consult with
the enslaved women right and the unsaved
woman had very different ideas one about
their bodies they had a very different
idea about their lives I mean first and
foremost
most of them rebelled so resistance and
rebellion is a continuous theme and so
we have this long tradition of enslaved
people having very different ideas about
their lives having very different ideas
about their bodies and so obviously this
whole idea of reproducing the slave
population locally did not sit well with
these enslaved women so that's one of
the conflicts that the book talks about
the other characters that I mentioned
the British Parliament the local
assembly in Jamaica they also didn't
necessarily agree with those ideas the
planters for example or the local
slaveholders rejected the idea that they
had any responsibility at all in the
local population not reproducing and so
they said you know well it's not the
labor conditions it's not our punishment
we're very kind slave masters and so
they had a different set of ideas they
pointed a finger mostly at the end state
women has been responsible for the
failure of the population to reproduce
locally and so what my book actually
does is that it goes through and charts
those various conflicts between and
slave women and planters or slaveholders
on the one hand abolitionists and
parliamentarians on the other hand and
the implications of those conflicts for
the lives of enslaved women and their
children of course a larger community in
which are these women more existence so
it's really a study in conflict and the
meaning of those conflicts for the lives
of enslaved people and what led you to
write the book inspiration or catalyst
well I think if you talk to most
historians it's often very difficult for
us to pinpoint one single thing one big
aha moment you know that lead us to
write a particular book it's often a
combination of factors but I think if I
had to choose one factor it would it
would be a letter that I had uncovered I
had discovered this letter written by a
local agent a plantation agent we
sometime refer to them as attorneys who
were acting on behalf of absentee
employers or absentee owners of the
plantations who lived in England
and the tradition within Jamaican slave
societies that those local attorneys
would write letters to employers in
England detail in and given reports
about what was going on in the colony
the ways in which they were managing the
plantations the ways in which they were
treating the enslaved people and so I
found this letter written somewhere
around 1804 from this local agent in
Jamaica to his employer in England and
in this letter he detailed the ways in
which he was changing around the labour
responsibilities of enslaved women so in
one part of the letter he explained that
enslaved women who were pregnant would
not work on their own they would work in
groups of three and by placing them in
groups of three to say lift canes to the
mill this would allow some women to rest
while others work so he was punctuating
their labour with rest period and when I
saw that it struck and note with me and
he struck a note with me because I sort
of read it through the lens of several
historian so Jennifer Morgan Kathy Brown
Vereen Shepherd they all have sort of
written about history of slavery in the
body and just you know the body in
general and the ways in which you know
the body sort of isn't just this thing
that we write about it is this thing
that forces us to respond to it in
certain ways and when I saw that letter
that talked about the ways in which this
local agent was responding to a woman
being pregnant and change in the labour
roles to respond to that pregnancy it
got me thinking about you know what
these other his stories had written
about the body of enslaved people and
what that actually meant in the context
of slavery and the other thing that that
struck me about this letter is I also
remember sort of reading in the
literature this idea that the
plantations were gender blind so slavery
was gender blind so men and women did
the same work without any attention to
differences in gender and that was quite
the opposite this letter was saying
something very different he was actually
saying that this local slave holder was
in fact paying attention to women so
there is a distinction between men and
women
and more than that he was also paying
attention to these women being pregnant
and change in the labor at least how he
was organized in labor around pet excuse
me around pregnancy and so that sort of
encouraged me to dig a little bit deeper
to find out you know was it simply a
unique case or were there other
experiences or other kinds of examples
that I might be able to uncover and so
that letter essentially took me down the
path of what essentially became
contested bodies okay and let's talk
about your the research that you found
and your methodology
well most historians again will tell you
that any history of women particularly
histories of enslaved women is
painstaking research and so I spent
years in the archives I think it took me
maybe about ten years to write this book
I spent a lot of time in the archive
it's a deeply archival book and in some
respects I am lucky and I'll say lucky
because the women that I'm researching
they're existing at a very unique moment
and this unique moment as I stated
earlier was a period of abolitionism and
one of the things that the British
Parliament did when abolitionists
started to campaign against slave trade
is to convene a series of investigative
committee committees and these
investigative committees are held
primarily by the House of Commons would
invite folks from every aspect of the
slave trade and slavery to come to the
House of Commons and answer or you know
give testimony to account for was
slavery really as horrible as these
abolitionists were charging so you had a
ship servant surgeon sorry
sailors captains traders doctors
planters so just about everyone who had
any kind of dealings with either the
slave trade or slavery appeared before
Parliament to answer questions and so
one of these essential sources that I've
had to rely on and you know one of the
sources that gives me quite a bit of
detail on these women are actually these
parliamentary records you know they
asked a lot of question about you know
what kind of labor were pregnant women
subjected to what kinds of punishment
were
any specific kind of allowances given to
them in terms of increased food rations
in terms of increased clothing
allowances and so these questions and
the responses became a very rich set of
sources but of course all these turns
again will tell you that their sources
are inherently biased and the kind of
bias that I was working with with these
sources is these planters obviously are
in trouble or in their in some other
trouble they have to prove to the
British Parliament that
oh those abolitionists are you know
making up story there they're not
telling the truth they're really making
on phone charges and so the potato
particular kind of bias within these
sources is that the planters would
exaggerate the extent of their
benevolence they would exaggerate that
oh yes we're actually you know making
life a lot more bearable for these women
and so yes on the one hand these
slaveholders did in fact make some
changes to women's our lives and women's
oven conditions but I had to figure out
how truthful were they being you know
how extensive were these changes and so
I had to counterbalance out those
witness testimonies by using other
sources so some of the sources that I
would look at were the private
correspondence so that same letter that
I talked about that got me involved in
this project was one of the you know one
of the kind of sources that I use so
private correspondence between local
agents in Jamaica who were right into
employers in England as well as if you
made more objective sources so these are
plantation inventories that would list
the number of enslaved people on a
particular plantation it would list the
number of children who were born at a
given time the number of individuals who
died it also lists the general work log
so you know how many and say people are
on a property what are the work that
they're involved in doing and so it's
painstaking research because you sort of
want to get as close as possible to the
reality of these women's lives and one
of the other sort of challenge that I
had to deal with is none of these
sources were actually written by the
enslaved women right so it's all these
slave holders up
parliamentarians their perspective that
were a first-person nothing in your eye
that's right nothing in the first-person
from these enslave people's perspective
and so what I had to do in the book is
to put it at the front and center to say
well you know these are the perspectives
of the enslaved people and this is my
best guess and what they might be
thinking what they might be getting at
in terms of how they're responding to
the slaveholders and so it's really you
know painstaking archival dig that I had
to go through and get in this work did
you come across any women's voices at
all I clearly obviously not women who
were enslaved but any you know the wife
of a plantation owner or any other kind
of woman's voice was heard in the
researcher it was a predominantly male
so yes and no it was predominantly white
men's voices there are some white women
that I haven't covered so planters wives
the governor's wife the the governor in
Jamaica from 1803 - I think 1804 his
wife sort of you know has this journal
that a lot of us historians have relied
on so there are occasional our records
from white women that I've been able to
access as well and the interesting thing
is that it's very difficult at times to
tell differently the perspective of a
white male planter from the perspective
of a white woman of his wife because
their economic interests in the
plantation in slavery their ideological
support of slavery were pretty much
identical so it was really very
difficult to disentangle a white woman's
perspective from a white males
perspective in terms of enslaved
people's perspective unlike the American
experience where for example they've
been able to rely on the WPA narratives
we don't sort of have a similar set of
sources for the Caribbean though we have
for example the narrative of an enslaved
woman named Mary prince whose owners had
taken her to England and then she was
able to escape to abolitionists and then
tell her story to these abolitionists so
there are these occasional sources that
were able to rely on
I'm very careful in my work not to sort
of use one person's story to tell
everyone else's story so even though
there are times when I pull on mayor
princes experience I try not to use that
to generalize and say well mayor friends
thought bass mayor friends experienced
that and so it must be true for either
and say woman I try as much as possible
to think of these women as having very
diverse experiences
okay let's you know it strikes me when
you were talking about the the first
report that went back to England talking
about how he the slave owner or whoever
was managing the plantation grouped
these pregnant woman together and it's
and my immediate thought was it seems
like he would have had to do that if he
wanted them to continue working because
depending on where they are on their
pregnancy how much work in a pregnant
woman really do of hard physical labor
my guess would be not a lot and it you
know it's very difficult for the women
so my next thought was what did you come
across in your research any means that
plantation owners or slave owners took
to not have the women slaves get
pregnant because it would have because
it probably slows down on production
yeah and also cost them extra in food
and clothing as you had pointed out
that's right that's right
so that is an interesting question and
that sort of the crooks of the book and
I sort of go through and explain that
the 17:8 is to 1834 which is a time
period that my work sort of senators on
is a moment of change it's a moment of
change for several reasons one of which
is before the 1780s before abolitionists
came up with this elaborate plan to end
the slave trade by way of getting these
women to reproduce the population
locally planters really were not as
invested in reproduction and they were
not as invested for several reasons one
they calculated as you've said that you
know it was probably too expensive
because they would have had to provide
for some kind of allowance for women
during pregnancy they would have had to
have extra rations for children and even
these children who were born it would
have been at least several years before
they would be viable laborers and so a
lot of planters before the 1780s were
not as willing to invest in caring for
pregnant women in caring for enslaved
children and in some respects as I had
mentioned earlier this is partly why
historian so said that the plantation
regime was gender blind because planters
were not as attentive to differences as
it pertains to sexual differences as it
pertains to the different needs of
childbearing women and so there is a
degree of accuracy in making that
argument but this changes in the 1780s
and the change is that abolitionist
agitation interests by the British
government and of course by 1807 when
the slave trade does in fact comes to an
end
planters quickly realized that the kind
of neglect and inattention that they had
given to childbearing women before the
1780s that could no longer continue and
so now was a real moment for them to
take stock of how they had treated and
slave women in terms of the kind of
labor roles that they were given in
terms of how they would be punished and
so this is sort of a real moment of
change that were seeing in terms of you
know and save women's experiences on
these plantations okay let's talk about
some of the conflicts that you had
mentioned earlier just give a couple of
specific examples if you would please
so that's dangerous when you ask
historians for example his thorns can
talk forever I think one of my favorite
conflicts that I talk about in the book
is a conflict between doctors and and
slave midwives healers and enslave women
so one of the things that stakeholders
started to do in the 1780s is they
started employing doctors and these are
white European doctors who are coming
out of England mostly and in some cases
Scotland to the colony to Jamaica and
they hire them for a number of reasons
they hire them to
ten specifically to pregnant women but
they also hire them to attend to the
general health care off the plantation
but the interesting thing is that before
this period in the 1780s there might
have been one or two doctors in the
Caribbean most of the health care
practices were actually performed by
enslaved healers and so when these uh
white doctors came out to Jamaica in the
1780s and especially by the 1800s now
seeking to take over health care on the
plantations the inside healer said wait
a minute you know this is my territory
this is sort of my domain and so they
didn't simply just roll over and allow
white doctors to manage childbirth and
to manage healthcare these women sort of
resisted the idea of having now these
practices under the control of white
doctors but even beyond that these and
slave women who were pregnant would not
willingly give over the care of their
bodies to these white doctors remember
that this is very much a racialized
social order and so whiteness sort of
came with this so the white doctors were
seen as allies of the planters and so
enslaved women didn't trust those
doctors so even though at times there
were conflicts I do talk about conflicts
between doctors and planters who had
very different ideas about how to treat
trial childbearing woman the enslaved
woman didn't trust these doctors either
and so they one refused to be treated by
them and then the the healers and
midwives who were part of the plantation
system before the coming of these
doctors also resisted these doctors
coming in and essentially taking over so
I'd say sort of that might be my
favorite conflict and to think of a
specific example they had these debates
about whether or not infants should be
bathed and if infants are allowed to be
bathed should they be bathed in hot
water or should they be bathed in cold
water and in slave women insisted that
you know infants should have bath you
should bathe the infant because you know
bathing them was an essential birth
ritual and they would use warm water and
the water warm water would be infused
with rum and the doctors had a very
different idea first and foremost
Europeans had a long and checkered
history with faith and they had
superstitious ideas that bathing would
sort of cause the body to deplete either
it's worth it would cause it to lose its
humoral balance and so they had these
prescriptions to say oh you shouldn't
bathe and if you did in fact take a bath
only certain areas of the body should be
washed and so there was this clash
between and slave healers and then slave
midwives with your European doctors who
are coming one with very different ideas
about bathing and also different ideas
about bathing infants and so one of the
biggest crash that I talk about in my
book is about the approach to bathe in
both the pregnant women as well as
enslaved children so I think that might
be one of my favorite examples of you
know the kind of conflict that is taking
place on the ground with enslaved women
and these European doctors who are
coming into Jamaica so what do you
ultimately conclude any of book so I
make several conclusions one of the
conclusions that I make and I think I
started by talking about the
abolitionists one of the conclusions as
it pertains to that aspect of my book is
that the abolitionists did not have the
freedom and equality of enslaved people
in mind it wasn't their central
objective the central objective of
abolitionists was to protect British
imperial interests British colonial
interests and the reason I make that
argument is that if abolitionists were
first and foremost concerned with
freedom and equality for enslaved people
then the moral outrage that they had
over slavery that would be sufficient
for them to say it doesn't matter if
this slave traders will lose the money
it doesn't matter what the economic
consequences of that loss might actually
be the slave trade is so repugnant the
slave trade is so inhumane that we
require that the slave trade to end
immediately instead what they did was to
create this very elaborate scheme to
continue the slave trade for ten to
fifteen years and to have women
reproduce the population locally and so
what I do is sort of you know make this
argument that abolition was first and
foremost about securing British colonial
interests and less so about equality and
freedom for the enslaved population the
other conclusion that I make is that
this period is often labeled as a period
of amelioration by historians so they
call the period between 1780s 1834
one of amelioration and we debate
whether or not the condition of the
ensei person had improved so you know
did as they read get better in its
silent years and I sort of shift away
from that argument and I shift away from
it because even where you might be able
to see where and say women for example
had greater access to food or had you
know a less demanding workload what
changed here in the period 1780 to 1834
is that there were new demands being
placed on enslaved women so the only
reason that planters gave them more food
or gave them more clothing ration or
mitigated their punishment was to be
able to harness their reproductive
potential and so for me it's difficult
to sort of get into this binary of
better or worse but to say that actually
we're seeing the very parameters upon
which slavery here was being built are
actually changing during this period so
we're focused on the wrong thing to say
you know that slavery got better in the
end of years so I think those are the
two major conclusions that I make in the
book well this has been fascinating
thank you so much for being here with us
today and sharing your work thank you
thank you for having me
for more information about professor
Turner and her research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at new
you